[Music]
this minion Dorcas trick kicks off
wall-to-wall movie min sanity G's movie
he can't wait five seconds before you
start minion adjust bring on the min
pocalypse already also like this is what
terrified parents were worried about
suffering through for 90 minutes very
nice of illumination to make it clear
from the beginning those fears were
justified Comcast all those fans of look
who's talking that thought all movies
had been missing over the last 30 years
we're opening credits involving the
conception and birth of a species with a
60s pop song backing track had those fan
petitions finally paid off
minion roll narrations minions have been
on this planet far longer than we have
and yet they've evolved into a
compulsively subservient species rather
than advance according to Darwinian
launch it also did the minions evolve
their trademark goggles or make them and
if so out of what man for that matter or
why weren't the underwater creatures who
could see throughout their entire first
stages dear God are we even two minutes
in yet
that one is Norbit he's an idiot that's
racist they all share the same goal to
serve the most despicable master they
could find so the producers of this
movie then why did the minion skirts
change from full skirts to just loin
leaves for the animation teams of the
different segments not allowed to talk
to each other it wasn't easy for these
guys but they never gave up clearly
somehow they managed to survive the
extinction of an entire species can't
blame this one just on the minions right
even if they thought it would somehow
stay upright why would they be
celebrating in this exact spot a new
master had a tendency to party all night
and sleep all day I swear to God I just
broke out into a cold sweat thinking
this might be some sort of Hotel
transylvanian mashup this would be the
peanut butter and chocolate of immature
CG kids flicks except the ingredients
are and more Reese's feces why would a
vampire sleep in a room with a giant
window in the first place seriously
started to think the minions are getting
a bad rap here this is the entire movie
in a snow shell stupidity followed by
laughter over and over and over and over
again it's like if Seinfeld did an
entire episode where Kramer just kept
manically entering rooms where do you go
when you need relief from the comic
relief he would not return until you
have found his tribe the biggest baddest
villain deserves so are we seriously
rooting for these little bastards
they've been in here for enough time
that like they could be trying to
recruit Hitler right try putting that in
the kids movie so what exactly is the
distinction and minions were
between the one-eyed and the twat is
that their gender differentiation and if
so I'm assuming the one-eyed monster is
the male ian feels like i should give
the movie credit for going almost nine
minutes without a fart joke but still a
fart joke Kevin felt pride narration the
movie continues as we are now ten
minutes into this thing with nothing
more than uninteresting narrated
backstory minion gibberish and the
occasional pratfall in fact let's just
tack on 50 sins here for the ton of
illumination
also Jesus jumping gibberish whose idea
was it again to Center a movie around
characters that don't actually talk
would be the equivalent of DreamWorks
releasing a Galaxy Quest spin-off with
the thermians speaking in their native
language for 90 minutes yes the banana
joke is a recurring bit and maybe was
funny at some point the overused shtick
aside where the did Stewart get a fresh
banana no one will be seated during the
minions walking across different types
of terrain portion of the movie hungry
castaway he sees people as types of
delicious food cliche I guess these
quads took their geographical strategy
from the actual Despicable Me movies
they were somehow able to row from
wherever the fuck they were in the
permafrost all the way to New York City
and there were no ships milling about
until right now Friday the 13th part 8
minions take Manhattan even in 1968
especially in 1968 I'm not buying that
the water outside of Manhattan is this
clean this Nixon jerk must have killed
with the under 10 historical politician
crab this movie is banana in my brain -
the banana through green I'm adding
another 20 sins for the banana of it I
guess the purpose of those goggles are
finally revealed and it's solely to
provide a zoom and enhance cliche is
this a changing room I mean I know
things were different in the 60s but how
did they build changing rooms big enough
to dress elephants also how is there no
sign out front to keep randoms from
wandering it you're telling me and
literally the entirety of history that
these yellow dumb Marines have existed
they've never learned how to mirror ok
not only that the announcer ladies see
one of the minions walking around and
did nothing about it
there's no overnight security at this
fucking highfalutin department store
I'll give the movie credit for picking
three shows that could have been on
prime-time at the same time in 1968 but
both the dating game and bewitched were
on ABC and therefore could not have been
airing at the same time also what are
the chances each time they change the
channel it's at the exact moment the
title car for the show comes up I'm
calling banana gates also also what
fancy department store in the 60s sold
popcorn sodas
villain Network channel and by top
secret you mean so easy to find 3 min
kamp oops accidentally there way to it
by using an umbrella and a blender got
it also how convenient that they turned
it on right at the beginning of the
expositional part of today's broadcast
schedule so what's up with the up skirt
though was this movie directed by Zack
Snyder then also directed by Joss Whedon
how did this black and white newscast
all the sudden out of color Despicable
Me franchise continues its overt assault
on physics providing zero explanation
about how the minions get on top of the
Brooklyn Bridge
I hate laugh tracks but at least if this
movie had one I'd know when the movie
itself thinks it's being funny growing
boy like creatures needs their strength
why are the minions so freaked out about
mrs. Nelson and her knife don't they
enjoy being around potential villainy it
was their whole thing if this family has
actual guns and bazookas why not use
those instead of that paintball
peashooter that jams easily pigtails I
know even more than the next guy that
movies have to exposition but
hyperactive child exposition is now
officially my least favorite way to go
about it we're here for so much fun it's
a crime what happens if a nom
villain-con attendee pulls up behind a
villainous Winnebago while that's going
down one of these water mind looking
ceiling decorations that no one will
even see and what the hell is this
fucking wrench for Lou he tries to be
clever about its grew and Nefario cameo
here but of course can't wait to grew
all over our faces even more before it's
over oh they don't golf guys
let's say we grant the time-travel works
this way why would their disappearances
be staggered and why would it be on
delay even the time travel in this movie
is trying to have a sense of fucking
comedic timing when I started out people
said a woman could never rob a bank as
well as a man well times change
who knew that minions was sandy B's prep
work for ocean's 8 there's no way that
overly excited gil friend here a
believes this or B would jump up and
shout about it or see how is this even
supposed to be funny
why they are all these villains many of
whom are famous enough to be featured in
magazines clamoring to work for another
villain loner lone gunman get it that's
the whole point
all these villains and yet I still have
the bear stuffed bear why am i holding a
bear because the movie needed Bob to
cough up the Ruby so that they'd be your
henchman now as to how it actually
happened that you ended up holding a
bear and Bob ended up swallowing a ruby
the movie is too busy trying to get from
point A to point T to actually care
enough to explain anything from F to you
singing in the rain how dare you move II
swear on the ghost of Gene Kelly there
is more humor and one single Donald
O'Connor pratfall than the entirety of
this movie the nerve damn there are
several casual deaths in this movie and
this is probably the casual list good ol
Big Ben how would we ever know which
movies happened in London without you I
love it because I love I know this is
the illumination aesthetic for drawing
humans but I can't stop thinking that a
69 between these two would be
potentially lethal checking out my kin
ham-handed ham handily hatches horrible
hammy humor yes we've reached the out of
Hope and aimlessly wandering phase of
this minions movie haven't I already
seen this in the fourth season of The
Walking Dead not only is the entrance to
the super secret control room unlocked
it's got automatic doors so you have no
choice but to discover that also how is
the wall of Technology even supposed to
be used why would you have monitors
gauges and buttons 20 feet out of your
reach in sight even in 1968 people were
aware that being in the same room with
something leaking radiation was not a
good thing right
I don't know don't say anything I won't
understand we could have said it better
ourselves sandy we couldn't have said it
better ourselves
the wolf offered the three piggies and
all their friends a job working for her
but how exactly the Scarlett know that
there are more minions all the three
little piggies had to do was just steal
one little crown wait didn't we already
get this bit of exposition about
stealing the crown earlier exposition me
once shame on you
exposition me twice I won't get
exposition again good luck getting that
crown tomorrow little piggies I know you
won't disappoint me but their henchmen
then she's the master criminal so
they're very likely to disappoint her
why wouldn't Scarlett have any ideas or
plans to share with them and or why
isn't she the one pulling off the heist
and having them assist her where needed
[Music]
whoa movie if you're gonna pretend to be
self-aware enough to make a location
card gag you're gonna have to start
actually explaining how these same
minions have existed since the beginning
of time but if the person that's being
hypnotized can't understand what the
Hypnotizer is saying then how is one
hypnotized movie it's time for this or
movie finds this funny
take your pick yeah I wish this was a
question someone brought up in the
writers room for this movie I get
they're small but there is 0% chance
this was big enough of space for all
three of them to hide even in a film
that repeatedly says yet this is an
animated movie so whatever guts
why wouldn't you use these go-go minion
arms and legs to simply reach out and
grab the crown all right because this
movie prioritizes silliness over
anything that makes a lick of sense
jeez movie spider-man too much is this
scene gonna end with an unconscious Bob
crowd-surfing in the carriage Bob who
appears to be a bald jaundiced child
fine okay that was actually funny but if
you think you're getting a sinner move
for one good joke you've got another sin
coming which but didn't Bob do exactly
what scarlet wanted him to do when
stealing the crown not sure I understand
all this hostility Wow are we really
filling time right now with this exodus
of the minion Knights nonsense why am I
supposed to care about how the rest of
these fellow yellows make it to English
discount Ethan Hunt so I guess they had
these yellow hats available on the
off-chance a minion would poke King
Arthur's sword out of the stone and
become King of England also how does
this actually work does Elizabeth have
to marry Bob what if there was already a
king minions brings up so many questions
that I'm seriously a hundred percent
fine with never having the answers to
why did the banners have just one on
Stewart is the one with one on right but
Bob's the king right right like any
modern country would ever stand for a
dolt of a leader who could barely speak
the language and is so narcissistic they
basically spend their lives outing out
their own ink and how exactly do the
minions speak partial English if they
can repeat and understand English
verbage then why aren't they just
speaking in English law
[Music]
seems a bit odd that this movie spent so
much of its budget on rights to 60s hits
that not one person in the target
demographic will have a clue as to what
it is I could have just as easily played
some public domain John Tesh and it
would have had the same effect unfunny
Corgi abuse is decidedly unfunny it was
it's a teeny weeny yellow blob can't be
unseen also this is fire Harrigan
threesome mean that minions have sex
drives and I just realized rule 34
applies to minions and I would like to
be done existing now thanks Jerry
apparently it's super easy to get into
Buckingham Palace so easy in fact I
can't understand why Scarlett hadn't
already stolen the crown a few times
prior to even hiring the minions just
give the job to this woman there are
laws like the laws that let you crown a
hill a phallic symbol because he pulled
a sword from a stone
based on these hecklers in the
background it looks like Parliament is
no more sophisticated than a Green Bay
Packers game and you had stolen not just
England but my heart and the last 90
minutes of my life the rest of your
worthless little lives
why exactly a Scarlett Jo Manson here
locking the minions away even if her
feelings got hurt it's been obvious
they're willing to do just about
anything for and are too stupid to
really cause her trouble what's the
upside to this idea they clearly don't
have necks
what exactly did herb think what
happened the hair in that picture it's
just too wavy lines for breeze would be
excellent it cinemasins
is what every respectable torture
chamber contains went obvious and easily
escapable drain minion to eat really so
the minions are like the Forrest Gump of
60s England my mama always told me that
life is like a box of minions it starts
out somewhat cute but very quickly
becomes annoying exhausting and full of
idiots as our now I'm gonna say
protagonists run around this giant screw
on chandelier which is apparently a
thing can someone tell me why I care
about what's about to happen
am I supposed to be rooting against
Scarlett who hasn't really done anything
all that evil am I supposed to want what
the minions want am I supposed to even
know what that is because if there's
just a series of pratfalls and gibberish
jokes and nothing else it basically
amounts to the world's worst try not to
laugh compilation video totally up to
the challenge this is no longer a
coronation
pretty sure you got to go through the
coronation process before you start
handing out execution orders but what do
I know England damn that's quite a
pop-up thunderstorm it was barely even
cloudy when the minions entered the
Abbey all of two minutes ago Kevin Kevin
I know you're out there no you don't but
the scriptwriters needed this moment so
of course Kevin just happens to be
watching I will do it Kevin if you are
not back here by Dawn and 10 seconds
later Kevin turns the corner and it's
already dawn how was he supposed to be
there that quit what if he hadn't even
seen that message not trying to fat
shame but seriously if none of the other
villains can outrun the sumo guy then
Kevin is in the clear huh Roger Goodell
actually has a writing credit on this
movie in what way could this machine
have ever been used that didn't result
in its own destruction
seems like a giant design flaw nope what
exactly did lipstick lady run into when
we see out the windshield there's
nothing directly in front of her is that
a completely implausible three story
fully functional 9 booster Space Shuttle
type rocket under your dress or are you
just happy to see me this joke is yet
another reminder that this entire movie
is simply as they say in England taking
the piss make yourself up bigger target
doesn't really matter how big Kevin is
if scarless just gonna display some
vintage stormtrooper aim Jesus more
innocent people die in minions than the
entirety of London has fallen drawer
Butler thy name is mud Easter Faso Who
am I kidding minions are immortal and we
all know it so if Kevin shrank then why
didn't the overalls also since when have
minions worn underwear not that I'm
complaining but this movie has been so
addicted to crack I'm almost wondering
if I'm personally responsible for
manifesting them I haven't seen Michael
Keaton and Allison Janney this wasted
since that legendary Batman West Wing
crossover party got out of hand out you
are sir Kevin well done but they're all
still going to jail for handing the
crown and in effect the entire country
over to a super criminal right because
that happened don't cry because it
happened to you because it's over
actually do both both works fine and
this movie does not paint a flattering
picture of the London police force has
anyone except the minions even trying to
stop group he was evil he was perfect he
was uh Nobby as and unnecessary
reference to a previous movie
Kelly Clarkson oh come on Bob Bob rise
and shine check check one syphilis
now it's down population you're oh no
God no God please no like it's the
fruits of the devil oh they do golf guys
the kids the original it was me her the
whole time the whole time the whole time
you would the whole time